right now to this story we've been
following all week Saudi Arabia is
getting ready to change its story about
the disappearance of a Washington Post
columnist in Turkey under pressure from
the US and other countries Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo spoke with Saudi
leaders this morning about Jamal
khashoggi sources tell CBS News the
Saudis are now willing to say that
khashoggi was captured inside their
consulate in Istanbul and then died
during his interrogation President Trump
who said Pompeo to Saudi Arabia
yesterday after speaking to the king
suggested role killers might have done
it Holly Williams is in Istanbul outside
the Saudi consulate where Khashoggi was
last seen Holly good morning good
morning sources tell CBS News that Saudi
leaders are preparing to admit to the
accidental killing of Jamal hisagi
despite denying that they harmed him or
even knew of his whereabouts since his
disappearance Secretary of State Pompeo
is in Saudi Arabia looking for answers
to the mysterious disappearance of Saudi
journalist Jamal hisagi Turkish
investigators were finally allowed to
search the Saudi consulate in Istanbul
yesterday spending around eight hours
inside the building her shocked G walked
into the consulate two weeks ago and
hasn't been seen since a u.s. resident
and outspoken critic of the Saudi
government her Schulte apparently needed
paperwork from the Saudi authorities to
marry his Turkish fiance Turkish
officials speaking anonymously had
already told journalists they believed
her Shoji was murdered inside the
consulate allegedly by a 15 man Saudi
team that arrived that day and left
Turkey in the evening Saudi Arabian
officials denied all involvement
insisting her shocked G left the
consulate and this weekend calling the
Turkish claims lies and baseless
allegations the question now is how much
damage this will do to Saudi Arabia an
oil-rich ultra conservative Islamic
Kingdom and a key US ally in the Middle
East the country's Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman has portrayed himself as a
reformer winning praise for finally
allowing women to drive
like being independent I don't like to
count on someone else to do my stuff for
me but in disgust over her shock G's
disappearance some business leaders have
already pulled out of an investment
conference in Saudi Arabia this month
sanctions are being discussed in
Washington Turkey's president read Jeb
hi everyone said today that
investigators are looking into toxic
materials here at the Saudi consulate
and will also be given access to the
Saudi Consul generals residence biana
Holly Williams in Istanbul thank you